[applause]
So I grew up in a deaf family. My mom is deaf. My dad is deaf.
My mom's parents are deaf. Almost all my aunts and uncles they were all born deaf.
And this usually prompts a lot of questions. I'm sure you've got some, so you know what?
I'm just going to answer the top three questions that I usually get
when people find this out so we can just get that out of the
way. Yes. I know sign language.
I learned how to talk. Because I'm not deaf.
And yes, I'll teach you all the dirty words, but after the show.
Now when I was seven years old my dad moved us to the woods of Texas. And I say woods - but this was snake-infested forest.
And we camped in tents. We didn't have running water - no electricity.
We didn't have plumbing so we used an outhouse. And we did all this while we were
clearing the land preparing for the arrival of a trailer. And
eventually my dad built us a one room tin shack that we all shared.
And my dad led this expedition for this trailer
and he dug a water line that tapped into a natural spring well.
He dug a septic tank and created a plumbing system so we didn't need that nasty outhouse
anymore. He even brought us electricity. He did this all on his
own and to me as a kid, man, this was like
he was like Daniel Boone and Frank Lloyd Wright and Ben Franklin just
all rolled into one. And I was his baby girl.
He would have done anything for me including risk his life.
There was this one time on the ride back from Galveston Beach. And I was riding
in the back of our Chevy pickup truck. And my flip flop just tumbled out of sight. I
don't even know how I lost it. But, but seeing it tumble down the Houston highway made me burst
into tears. And my dad saw
this - saw me crying in the rearview. And he would have none of that so he brought the
Chevy to a screeching halt. Backed up down the highway. Jumped out
and ran across four lanes of traffic.
Cars are swerving, dodging people, screaming and honking, it was
mayhem. And I wasn't crying anymore. And my dad - he got that flip flop - he raised
it up like a trophy and he ran back, swerving through, dodging cars. And
he was -  he, he gave it back to
me. And he said, "Don't cry, baby girl. Don't cry."
He was a superhero. And he was my
dad. But he was also a husband, and not a very good one
according to my mother. After 22 years of marriage she had gotten fed up with the
spontaneous lifestyle of his - this wild life of the
party and, you know, the financial troubles that came with it. Oh, we had gotten the trailer,
but the trailer got repossessed. And we moved back into that one-room tin shack.
And so we relocated to Fort Worth. My mom and I shared a, a two-bedroom apartment and
my dad got some crappy studio down the
street. And, now I knew about the money troubles because as a child of deaf
adults or a CODA, I answered the phone. And
I interpreted the bill collectors' calls. I negotiated payments. So I knew
about this side of this, their, their troubles.
But I didn't really know about their fighting. Because unlike hearing parents who might
shout you would overhear shouting. I didn't hear them because they fought behind closed doors.
So I also didn't see them.
But, uh, one
night. One night I did see them fight. It was August 15th, 1988,
and something woke me up. Which, as a CODA,
should have been a signal that something was not right. Because, you know, one of
the, the false assumptions about deaf people, is that they're quiet? No.
They have no regulation at sounds. They are burping and slamming cabinets
and banging pots and pans. They are noxiously loud. And as a CODA,
you just tune out
the sounds of everyday life. But this night, is like
three in the morning. And something woke me up, and I went to investigate. And I
saw the light was on in my mom's bedroom.
And I peered in, and I see her lying on the floor. And my dad
is straddling her, and his arm is cocked back, ready to punch. And, and
seeing me in the doorway made my mom, like, shift her head. And in that split second
my dad ?[slapping sound]? hit the floor.
And the- missed her face by a fraction of an inch. If I hadn't been in
the doorway he surely would have hit her. And in hearing this thunderous crack of his knuckles
on the concrete floor, with that cheap carpeting over it - it stunned me and,
and I just backed up away from them. They scrambled to their feet and everyone's screaming and crying,
my dad is threatening to kill her and then kill himself.
And I have never seen my dad hit my mom. I've never had him lay
a hand on me. He never spanked me my whole life.
This was terrorizing. So I raced to my
bedroom and I called 911.
Now my first instinct was to protect my dad.
See in the deaf community, stories were often circulated about
how, um, the police would show up and a deaf man wouldn't know that the
police were commanding them to stop, or drop their weapon, or put their hands up. And the deaf
person of course didn't know that they were being yelled at and so didn't obey these commands and they were shot dead.
This is a story that I would hear all the time. And so my first thought to
the operator was please make sure, make sure that the cops know that my dad is deaf
and he might not do what they say. But I'll be here, I'll take care of it.
And so I tell my parents that the cops are on the way and then they calm down and they sit in the dining room and
that's when I noticed there are holes all over the dining room wall. And, uh,
I think well, maybe that's what woke me up. I don't know, but when the cops arrive,
they don't care about the holes in the wall. They don't care what I witnessed. They don't care
about what the 911 operator told them. All they really wanted to know
was the status of my parents' relationship - were they still married.
Now. Yeah. Technically they were still married. You know, they were separated, my dad -
his name isn't even on the lease, I told them. Well, that didn't matter. Did he have personal
belongings here? Well, yeah, he had
some clothes hanging in the closet, and toiletries. Well,
that gave him a right to be there.
The laws were different then. This is before the Violence Against Women Act. This is 1988.
And what happened behind a family's closed doors was their business - a weird don't ask, don't
tell policy.  He, therefore, had a right to be there.  All they could
do was ask him to leave. Ask him to leave, not tell him.
So after twenty minutes of negotiating, my dad finally says, "Okay, fine. I'll
go." And the cops assure me that they will follow him and make sure he's out
of harm's way, our way, even though he was clearly blitzed and in no condition to drive.
But hey, if they didn't care, I didn't care, and they were
gone. And my mom and I just, we didn't even hug.
We were just shocked, stunned I guess, and, and uh, we just went back to
our bedrooms. I mean, like, what do you, what do you after you've witnessed this?
Go to sleep. So I'm waiting. Trying
to fall asleep. But the adrenaline's still pumping through me, and, I'm thinking about working the next
morning and, and that's when I hear just this tremendous
crash. And I leap out of bed, and I see my dad charging down the hallway straight at me
and one body slam he has knocked the front door completely off its hinges.
Just destroyed it. And I grab this rotary phone that's sitting by my
bed and I start to dial 911 which, I gotta say in the
age of rotary phones. Nine?
Really stupid number, to have to dial in an emergency.
It hasn't even gotten back to its starting position and my dad's already
reached me. He's got the cord in his hands like he's going to crack a bullwhip. You know and he goes
like that, and rips it right out of the wall.
He corrals us and pushes us into the dining room and he makes me and my mom and him sit there while
he interrogates my mother about who she's sleeping with.
And I, you know I can't hear them fight, obviously, so I just cover my eyes. This is a way to,
I guess, maintain some dignity for my mother and also because I don't want to know these details about
my parents'
relationship. And hours pass, and I can see that the sun is
rising - I'm not going to work in the morning. And my mother is not giving my father any
father any emotion - she's just a blank slate. And this starts
to, I guess just get on my dad's nerves to the point where he decides to turn his
attention to me. He wants to make sure that I know what a horrible human she
human she is and what a horrible wife she is. And he starts
he starts to graphically describe her sex life to me. Your mother
Your mother is an S L U T
I search his face
I search his face for a sign of who, who, who
is this person? Where is my
dad. And he's searching my face. For a sign that
I'm on his side. And I wasn't. This made
him snap. He grabs my mother by the neck in one move, slams her against the wall
and starts choking her to death
death. And her heels are like digging into the wall like she's trying to pull herself up
and she's got her hands around his wrist like, just trying to get some leverage - anything.
And I think,OK, what can I do I? I can grab a finger, if I can just grab
one finger and bend it backwards, he'll have to let go from the pain so I just try to focus on just
one finger. If I could get my fingers behind one finger. And I
And I couldn't. He was so strong. He was too strong. And my mom's face is turning purple, her
eyes are bugged out, and the vein on her forehead is fat and
burst and so I change tactics. I, he's so focused on my mom
my mom's eyes that I get between their faces and I make my dad look at me. Look at
"Look at
me. It's Kambri, your baby girl."
And his eyes start to well up with tears. And I see, oh, it's working, it's working. I'm gonna keep doing
keep doing this. So I keep saying it. "It's Kambri. It's me, your baby girl. Your baby girl."
And with that,
he just lets her go. So I race to the dining room phone, which thank God was a
was a touch tone. And dialed 911. And I
hear the operator say, like, "911, this is an emergency" or "What's your emergency?"
Um, but my dad, he's already reached me. He grabs the phone and slams it into
the cradle. He grabs my mother by the back of her hair, forces her into a seat
and pulls her head back and now has a knife that he's pulled out of his back pocket, at her throat, that
he's made long and lean.
But since he's deaf, what he doesn't know is that the whole time, the phone is ringing.
911 had called immediately back.
And I have a choice. This whole time I'm thinking, I have a choice. I can either
try this baby daughter routine, or I can grab the phone. And I
And I know the baby daughter routine won't work. I'm the enemy now. He
sees this. So, I made a choice and I ran for the phone and I screamed, "He's back!"
And in that instant, seeing my mouth moving, my dad, he knew the jig was up. He knew it was done. So
he dropped the knife and tried to make everything look like it was in order again.
And the cops, they were there in a blurry instant. And one officer is
tending to my mother. And while
they're working with her, the other one asks me to interpret my father's Miranda rights.
father's Miranda rights. So I
start to interpret them. You have the right to remain silent.
And that's when the other officer is like, "Oh, maybe we can do that back at the station."
Yeah. Maybe.
And they off, tromp through the front door.
And they left me and my mom just to pick up the pieces, and for a variety
of reasons my mother didn't press charges. And because of the laws being what they were then,
my father was never really charged with anything too serious. He, he got four years probation.
And over time, I discovered
discovered that my father had been a cheat from day one. My mom - he had cheated
on my mom the day they were married -  the whole first year of their
marriage. He had been abusing her, the whole time too, but
because she used to make him fight behind closed doors where I couldn't hear and I couldn't
couldn't see, I didn't know these things. And so she had given
me this superhero of a dad. This -
crazy memories of
just this wild carefree father. And that's the one that I have
to choose to remember. That Daniel Boone, that Ben Franklin, and
Frank Lloyd Wright. All wrapped into one.
one. The father who would rescue
rescue my flip flop.
Because he thought it meant something to me.
Thank you.